you came on my radar I was in the UFL
you had your your fight there was not
too long ago you won the fight he's a
amateur fight and then I'm with you I
think it's time to go pro but your dad
seemed to be a little bit of a hater on
that
yeah I mean I understand where he's
coming from though because uh especially
after that fight
um I do have a lot of stuff I still need
to work on yeah and from three minutes
to five minutes is a big jump even
though it doesn't seem like a huge huge
difference so you know I I do agree with
but at the same time I'm getting older
too you know and it's it's starting to
it's starting to become you know harder
especially in the gym like everything is
starting to move at a different pace now
so how old are you 23. I mean not that
old yeah
me and holder man my back hurts damn it
23.